once everything was awesome
now everything okay Lucy I brought you
coffee coffee the bitter liquid that
provides the only semblance of pleasure
left in these dark times oh my gosh Ness
did I interrupt you brooding just now
times have changed
you need to change with them we have to
be tough and battle-ready
[Music]
burning the doors
closing
oh the pain it's Jane so cold
see that wasn't so bad nothing got in
it's all my fault
hang on you're France planet we're going
to save Lucy destroyed
you mind if I save your life not at all
who are you names Rex danger vest galaxy
defending archaeologist cowboy and
Raptor trainer I don't get it
we'll help me rescue my friends you
don't want to go anywhere near that
sistar system it's ruled by an alien
coin only the toughest you're gonna get
out of there alive i'm mcqueen whatever
I would not be I'm getting super evil
vibes here I could change my form to
something else if this makes you
uncomfortable
hey guys they'll go back don't worry was
much more palatable double dot on your
face
who are you I'm your worst nightmare Oh
me when I'm late to school and I forgot
my homework and my pants are made of
pudding no I don't
you